this one's a tough one for me because  I'm such a yes man but I like it as we  head into November  so much opportunity to say yes to  everything if you're on the offense if  you're like me but the reality is knows  matter now my nose  come in the form of people around me  having admins having Chiefs of Staff has  really helped me prioritize which is  really what this is about this is about  prioritization  most people actually have a ton of fear  and they don't say yes enough but for  the people that do say yes or have a lot  going on using November and this little  clubber November as an opportunity to  say no to things that are stretching  within while you are focusing on big  tasks at hand if you were fortunate this  November to have big tasks at hand  whether at home or in the office  try to practice now a couple more times  or  really figure out what this is about  which is prioritization